borders are kamala harris is in honduras
today to intend the inauguration of the
newly elected president castro who's a
socialist and will probably steal all
the money we send him while he keeps
sending us caravans
most people don't want to leave home if
they leave it is usually
because they are either fleeing harm
or they simply cannot satisfy their
basic needs the area of cooperation and
work that we will do together on
economic prosperity will be pivotal
to that issue in particular of irregular
migration
former vice president mike pence joins
me now good to see you mr vice president
great to see you jesse congratulations
on the new show thanks for having me on
thank you very much we're very excited
so when you did the handoff with kamala
harris during the inauguration i'm sure
you gave her some very sweet personal
advice
do you think she's taken your advice i
mean what did you tell her did you tell
her to go find out root causes
you know well look that's an old mantra
of uh back in the days of the obama
biden administration was that
was that the problem of illegal
immigration was driven by root causes i
really wasn't that surprised when she
skipped over the border
and started to talk about root causes
and look she's down in honduras
uh the new president she's a socialist
but you know frankly jesse i'm more
concerned about the social issues
associating with here in washington dc
than i am in the northern triangle the
the reality is
this administration unleashed the worst
border crisis in american history
because on day one
president biden undid
the policies that president trump put
into effect that reduced illegal
immigration by 90 percent that remain in
mexico policy as you know jesse was
working
we built hundreds of miles of border
wall this administration stopped
construction on the wall they've left
massive gaps in the wall but really by
undoing the policies and focusing uh on
on economic development in in central
america is a prescription for more what
we saw last year two million
illegal immigrants coming across our
border december was the highest month in
history
the biden harris administration is
failing the american people at our
southern border failing on our economy
and frankly failing the country at home
and abroad well they're failing in the
cities too this crime is out of control
you remember joe biden he was never
like this before he was pretty pro-law
and order supported the police officers
what do you think's changed with joe
biden
well i
you know i i've said as i've traveled
around the country over the last year
that
you know
joe biden
won his party's nomination but uh bernie
sanders won the party yeah and the truth
of the matter is that the politics of
the socialist left are in the saddle uh
in the democratic congress look i served
in the house of representatives back in
the day with bernie sanders
he is a straight up unreconstructed
european style
socialist and the politics of the left
including
all the politics of of a defund of the
police are driving are driving this
administration and frankly
again as you know i've spent the last
year we moved back home to indiana but
i've spent a lot of time moving around i
get to spend a lot of time with members
of law enforcement and cities around the
country and i got to tell you their
hearts are broken by what they're seeing
happening you mentioned driving that's
expensive now you fill up it's an extra
20 bucks every time you go do it i know
when you get to washington or you're in
the white house or at the capitol
everybody drives you around you have
chefs taking care of all your needs your
food so you're not really connected to
the purchasing lifestyle of the american
public would you suggest joe biden and
kamala harris maybe leave the white
house maybe go to a gas station go to a
grocery store and maybe see for their
own eyes how pricey things have gotten
well
one of the advantages of no longer being
vice president is i get to drive my own
car
one of the disadvantages is i get to pay
for my own gas what are you driving
these days mr vice president i got to
tell you i'm driving a ford and uh
and i'm currently in the market for a
truck
but i got to tell you the gasoline
prices are like nothing i have ever seen
but again once again it's the result of
the policies of the biden harris
administration we had achieved
energy independence for the first time
in 70 years by unleashing american
energy as never before and uh energy
prices were low across the board
from day one i mean think about this
jesse
that here's an administration one of the
first things they do is shut down
an american pipeline the keystone
pipeline
and authorize the construction
of a russian pipeline to
germany uh to make germany and europe
more dependent
on russian national natural gas i i you
know the
the policies of this administration are
i want to say that they they make no
sense but frankly they do make sense to
the radical left when's the last time
you talked to former president trump you
guys good
you know we talked last summer and uh
you know i've said many times we
you know that
it was difficult january 6 was difficult
it was a tragic day in the life of the
nation
i know i did my duty under the
constitution of the united states but
the president i sat down in the days
that followed that we spoke about it
talked through it we parted amicably
mike pence who you'll be seeing in your
neck of the woods and a ford driving
through
give them a hunk mike
[Laughter]
promise i will thanks jesse